imagine a world in which bosses can
dictate how workers manage their
eyebrows could force applicants to take
pregnancy tests and could require them
to wear makeup to work
sounds like the 1950s but these are all
policies one airline or another has had
four female employees right up to the
present day
same people everywhere welcomes the news
this week but virgin no longer force
employees to wear makeup during flights
until we realize that this had even been
happening in the first place other
airlines still make their crew wear
lipstick and blusher and allowing women
to wear trousers to work is only a
recent development I am wearing makeup I
often do you may question the logic of
that one study found that women exposed
themselves to more than 200 harmful
chemicals through their morning PT
regime before they've even left the
house
we are poisoning ourselves and losing
thousands of pounds and days of our
lives for the privilege if that's a
mistake
it had better be one we choose not one
we are forced into and especially not
one we are forced into for fear of
losing our jobs from companies run by
men I think you've entirely lost the
plot that is the firm version I'm
surprised version I think there's a load
of PC virtue signaling nonsense I can't
imagine any girl who works for virgin
who would turn up for work without that
makeup
25 26 year old girls don't want to be
without makeup because they would rather
be dead than be see various make out
seriously and I know a lot of the Virgin
hostesses and they are the ones they
actually they're probably the smartest
people are the smartest girls are right
this is an inner virgins reasons for
doing this really got up my nose
they says they walk the helps women to
express themselves do you know the girls
don't need to express themselves the
servant drinks and they're serving the
bacon row from the trolleys they don't
need to express themselves on the place
way if they are so determined to wear
makeup why does it matter then because
they're not saying you because you don't
let me finish
oh it's anyway because they took a job
the rules were very clear it says
they're not asking them to take
themselves all they say is lipstick and
blusher it's not a big deal and I just
didn't listen the reasons for doing this
all wrong it says we want to help we
want to help people be themselves
being themselves turns out to be a
slovenly bloom and mess I don't want to
be served by someone how much like
they've just fallen adipose you know
what I'm almost unshockable at stuff you
say but I I'm because I thought to be
small I mean who says wear makeup can
steal my makeup women who don't don't
women wear makeup for lots of reasons
one it makes them feel good it makes
them look good they still you don't have
to wear makeup for this program yeah I
am right this is me without makeup I'm
not ashamed of how I look without me I
don't know why don't you look like I
said it's choice we should be allowed to
choose whether we want it and we come
into this with some trepidation well I
do notice though that when we going to
make up here it does take a bit longer
for you guys this does for us and my
whole experience in television over the
years is when you're scheduling you said
you're much longer for women than you do
for many makeup there is someone's give
me the statistic that I'm almost
embarrassed that use which says that the
average British woman spends nine days a
year applying makeup where they got it
from have no idea look I get that you
need to have somebody because look
they're not just dishing out bacon rolls
are now right they are the safety for
that plane
they are the safety for that plane so
when you're cutting around to want to
present a professional actual image to
people then if the airline had theme
that that's what they wanted to wear and
then so we're not join the army they
said you've got to shave even have your
hair cut short though I didn't question
it so welcome possible to do that I'll
shave me beard off and I've cut my hair
short do you not I mean so livering CPR
wearing a tight pencil skirt manicured
nails I do to get it so long as you're
presentable and they can do the job but
they do know the Kier that somebody is
deciding you say well you say you know a
lot of virgin I do
well I knew well very well images
they do that we should keep they do like
they do like to look smart but here's
what F was said no one's going to stop
so if our 25 year old girl wants to put
on a ton of makeup woman she can still
do it
but equally the girl she's working
alongside if she doesn't she doesn't
have to I think is an enlightened
decision thank you can I let you hear
what the young female writer Rebecca
Reed has to say about this the problem
that has been going on is that you have
cabin Kerber genders of all genders and
women worrying expected by makeup men
weren't so what they were saying is a
male face with no makeup on it is
professional a female face with no
makeup on it is unprofessional nobody
agrees that nobody thinks that a woman's
face should be considered not good
enough for purpose if it's not covered
in makeup and of course anybody who
still wants to wear the makeup still can
and anybody who still wants to wear the
skirt rather than the trouser still can
it's about giving women little freedom
of choice in the workplace okay you may
be stuck in the girls who choose to be
air hostess would rather be seen did try
to achieve here choice no it's not
choice it's the announcement of having
to actually announce that is actually a
bit smaller why did you have to say that
why did I agree with you my saying that
they should have a choice pressure and
by the way Carol shaken blusher is be a
virgin were requiring women's wear
foundation and actually if you look at
the policy it's so interesting the
policy for women is like 10 15 20 points
the policy for men is like make sure
your shades and look like entrance and
also the rug but it's not just rules for
bullet either American ila airlines have
a rule that guys have to look out for
their year here in the nose hair which i
think is perfect I think that's also
right as well it's about groin
we don't get nine hours to do it no
[Music]
she's caught she's a dating expert and
she's called Nadia Essex it's a PR PC
nonsense quite frankly I know many my
sister-in-law worked for virgin for a
decade
she loved the dress code she loved the
makeup code
she loved the glamour of it all and it's
just gets to a stage oh what's gonna
happen everyone's gonna turn up to work
in scruffy jeans and unwashed armpits
and expect that that's okay to be
serving me my chicken or beef on a
flight absolutely not shall we relax a
dress code and they're relaxed a
grooming code girls some girls might tip
off looking at how I said it I said some
girls I don't think the majority of
virgin girls at the moment you can't
have unwashed armpits
present ability they're just saying as a
woman being professional presentable
doesn't mean you have to now have a face
but makeup by the way pop stars are
among the group who wear the motormate
picture of you this okay you're a
beautiful girl right just picture with
no makeup on would you go to a big
important meeting that you had with no
makeup well I've just had a bit shown on
a very big important meeting I might
definitely feel input it's important I
have the choice and if someone told me I
had to wear makeup for that meeting I'd
quickly a lot less like this is
important to because we've mentioned I'm
sorry but as we've mentioned virgin and
I will come back to you but must just
get this in executive vice president
Mark Anderson we want our uniform to
truly reflect who we are as individuals
while maintaining that famous Virgin
Atlantic's style we've been listening to
the views of our people and as a result
of announced and changes to our styling
and grooming policy that support this
not only to the new guidelines offer an
increased level of comfort they also
provide our team with more choice on how
they want to express themselves at work
I think I just wanted to show you Alicia
Keys who's one of my favorite singer
songwriters and she voluntarily stopped
wearing makeup because she felt it was
unfair to portray representations of
being high
made up as natural swimming shoes
beautiful women on the planet she is
extreme extremely attractive but I think
that that was brave and I think no don't
break that has got other pop style
dousing themselves and makeup it just
shows that women want choice Carol it's
2019 right garlic doors to manual we
must move on before we go there's just
time for this now lots of people think
politicians are all the same rolling out
cliches and sound bites and never
answering the question but they're not
all like that as conservative
backbencher Johnny Mercer proved when he
appeared this week on the political
party podcast with comedian Matt Ford
here's a selection of his best bits my
life up here I've got I've got to be
honest is is pretty crap right so you
know I live in a hotel right I'm
basically like Alan Partridge I have I
genuinely have my own place in 2015 I
won I was like what do I do with this
boat so I I thought here's a good idea
I'll Drive it up to London and I'll live
on it in my incredibly naive mind I had
this picture of you know waking up in
the morning having a coffee by the water
you know in November they found a body
why go to schools you know little you
know little Sammy says I want to be an
MP I say Johnny Mercer you win our
straight foul talker of the week Phil
he's ex-military from the same
background as myself absolute laud him
for that I really do what top doing our
next Prime Minister I suspect he's the
front-runner isn't he he's in the in the
next intake people inspiring a young
generation yes and also he's hot
that's it for this week on the pledge
but don't forget you can join in the
debates on Facebook or Twitter see you
next time